all of the exciting things that happened
in each of our lives right like okay
this other guy was like well i'm not
rich i'm a regular guy and i was like
that's fine but like i'm not a regular
girl
like
i'm i'm not so like
if you are going to date me like either
you have to be able to handle that or
you yourself also have to not be like
regular like i don't think
like just an average person like that is
boring
okay so
is there like a do you care okay would
you be cool with a guy that makes less
money but he's very he's a hard worker
like he's ambitious
yeah
okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes 45 000 a year
would you date him
he wouldn't be able to afford my
engagement ring i'm getting an eight
carat cushion cut vintage engagement
ring if you make 45 000 a year it would
take what
four years no eight years to afford how
much
i don't know anything about ranks how
much how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you want a two
hundred thousand dollar are you insane
my ring has to sparkle from across the
street like you have to see that [ __ ]
it's gonna blind people well that's so
superficial that's like so superficial
but it's about so much more than that
it's about the fact that you can afford
that right i go to yoga with this girl
who has an eight carat diamond
engagement ring yeah the weed company
and drives an audi
so it's about more than just it's about
the fact that you can afford that but
you you're you ain't her you ate her
because i'm worth it she's going to end
up cute is it cubic zirconia that's what
she's got it's a fake one that's what
she's going to end up with and this is
this is this is the thing is that these
are supposed to be business-minded women
i remember when i was talking to my
mother about marriage you know how much
my ideal wedding costs
it cost 15 hundred pound including the
ring and the honeymoon 1500 pounds that
is it
too many people start relationships in
debt she hasn't got a car but she wants
a 200k that's ridiculous so you're gonna
have a you're gonna have a two 200k ring
and eat what chips mashed potato
well yeah i get into here here just wait
okay well i'm just thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys
because i'm telling they're not but not
not in a good way not in a good way i'm
telling you like my dad would but if my
mom asked for that from my dad my dad
would have told her to go find a new
boyfriend because there was no way in
hell he was gonna spend two hundred
thousand dollars on an engagement ring
and that's
no and that's a multi-millionaire in the
top half a percent who had 10 kids my
mom never
he went he said he's built to the
becoming that he wasn't that originally
right
he wasn't well he was making like six
figures in his early 20s oh nice so so
any any women woman with half a brain
would think this is a good this is a
good but my dad's like he's good with
money he's not like do you hear she like
yeah nice yeah i don't know i see it
because like do you hear how she's
trying to diminish like like she's like
oh well he built himself to be there
like
what what have you done
he's there that's what you want he's
he's there that's the whole point is
that he's done it and it's like i grew
up with the men that you so called one a
date like all of my brothers make six
figures that are older than me so it's
like
she doesn't listen at all she feels like
she knows it all i always say would you
prefer a poor man with ambition or a
rich man with none oh a poor man with
ambition she wants a beach family poor
man with ambition because she didn't get
it she was one of the reasons
i've dated the opposite and it is not
yeah
like to me that's like such an unwise
investment to spend
200k
diamonds appreciate
oh my god no no
oh my god no
that's like i would rather put that in a
college fund for our kids or like yeah
they'll have that too
but this just sounds like not like real
to me you know really yeah like i don't
know for me like i told you like my my
status is going up like i just did a
music festival where i made 30 grand
over there in one weekend you know what
i mean like i need somebody who can be
on that level right but the problem is
like guys don't care about your money
right
there
i i know but it doesn't like
you know like
i'm just i think you're gonna miss out
on a lot of guys with like this crew
like to me these are like crazy high
standards so
today i listened to my dating coach
she said you do not get your expectation
you get your minimum standard
see i wish
i i have more experience these days
these type of these type of women were
new to me at the time because i wasn't
used to like the girls i grew up around
really weren't this crazy like i grew up
with athletes i've never seen anything
like that before yeah and so i like i
wish i could talk to her now because now
that i've dealt with crazy yeah i know
how to like talk to them in a more
direct way but at the time i'm like what
are you doing i'd like to see i know
like where are you now you know i could
oh i could tell you look at it i'll show
you she's still doing the same [ __ ]
because you can do tick tock
taylor the sparkle
so she's still single yeah of course she
is she's always going to be single she's
got bad that's it she's yeah because she
acts like like this is when a lot of a
lot of girls come in older
and
they raise their standards higher
even though their products like like
they don't put them that's like kevin
samuels used to say after 30 you put
yourself on sale
like even because it's one thing to come
in a guy with like a humble a humble
attitude
you know what i'm saying like a lot of
guys will date a girl with a kid but
like the problem is the girls that have
kids will act like they're better than
the men yeah like they don't humble
themselves and it's even with her like
you've never had a boyfriend you're in
your 30s like that's crazy yes she's
never had a boyfriend no never and she
wants that ring
and she thinks that she's gonna get a
man and she's never had a boyfriend but
the thing is is that now that's even
worse because nowadays you've got all
the tick tocks and the instagrams who
the hell is going to want that no but if
he was a man and he was looking at her
page oh no look at this look at this
this is one of the least self-aware
things and having the waiter filming
and then and then she's like she wants a
six-figure man and he and he like
politely was like oh you're gonna film
this too like you realize he was i think
he's been telling tongue intrigue and
she's just like oh thank you
and then she's like oh i'm an influencer
that's like right over here you have a
hundred thousand followers on tick-tock
you get 200 views and you're like i
i've been i don't even call myself an
influencer
and it's just i think people just look
at to laugh because
like and she's not a bad looking girl if
she didn't do it she's not great no her
attitude makes her like i'd say she's
fine but like like i don't think she's
like hot i just think she's average but
like her attitude a lot of the prettiest
girls i know the ugliest inside they're
really ugly
and and
no look at her flared nose no
why would you who has a dating coach
what's 35 years old and you've got a
dating coach
i mean at 35 don't you know how to date
or doesn't a dating coach tell you don't
take out your phone no you see this is
the problem like this is a red pill fact
so or basically like a hundred percent
of women want twenty percent of men yeah
so girls have been going through their
their twenties and their even their
early thirties like they're side chicks
yeah and so they've never really had any
relationship experience so they don't
know how to like vet men properly
and so it's like they get to 35 and
they're still like mentally a teenager
because they've never had a real
relationship
and so it's like yeah so that's like
what you see is she's mentally still a
teenager
there's a lot of that yeah there's a lot
and like an elder and that's why like
you can't have a conversation about like
hey it's not about happiness like that's
an adult conversation but like it's like
you're talking to teenagers but you know
what sooner or later it's going to
balance itself out
the mental women ratio because the men
are going to realize that half of your
women are stupid if you don't want you
and it's going to even itself up
and then you're going to end up
lonely and barren with your dogs no
that's what happens yeah like
i don't i don't see like i don't see
her getting like saved unless